I've been keeping a secret from you guys
and that is I'm gonna be a day we found
out that Marzia is pregnant first in
November and I'm just so thankful
everything's been going well so far I am
sitting very comfortably waiting for
um Marzia because she's at the clinic
she's doing her Echo today although
emergency has been dealing with the
sickness she's been taking it like an
absolute champ are you tired we got a
pretty girl over here
so yeah I'm gonna be a dad I'm so
excited it's kind of strange to me it's
entering new territory but I feel really
ready and so does Marcia it's strawberry
season not just in Japan but also for
America who has been craving
strawberries during her entire pregnancy
I feel like that's lunch breakfast
dinner
I just feel so lucky to start a family
with the woman I love and I know
whatever is ahead of us together we can
do it
what
I was really fortunate to have great
parents growing up so I want to pass on
what they gave to me and we're so happy
for you and my system was loving and
caring person I know so I have
absolutely no doubt she will be an
amazing mother
you can see your pregnant belly looks
like a little penis you have to figure
but I promise to help along the way and
be the best dad I can possibly be
I can't wait to meet this kid